hello everyone and welcome to a really
wild Armageddon game between Wesley so
and hikarnakamura even though we already
had the finals of air things Masters
between Magnus Carlsen and Hikaru
Nakamura uh now Wesley and Hikaru are
playing uh for the privilege of facing
Magnus again in the grand final of the
air things Masters it's uh it's a weird
new New Concept uh but uh as uh Magnus
already defeated Hikaru in the in the
finals if Hikaru now goes into the Grand
Final against Magnus and he beats Magnus
uh then they will play another match uh
sort of because Hikaru already lost the
Magnus but if Wesley wins uh and then he
faces Magnus in the Grand Final then
Wesley will be the winner of it all so a
bit of a weird New Concept but uh will
you know could be interesting we'll see
how it goes so uh first you have to win
the game and it's Armageddon uh the the
first game okay Hikaru was naughty car
Wesley was was better a little better
but he couldn't pull off a win uh second
game they agreed to a draw very quickly
and now this is Armageddon let's see
what happens we have Pawn the E4 by
Wesley and Hikaru got the black pieces
as he bid eight minutes which is
incredibly low but he he really wanted
black to
uh sort of um I make his chances in
Armageddon go go a bit uh higher but if
anyone can win on demand it is Wesley's
Soul so E4 E5 Knight to F3 Knight to C6
and now D4 Wesley goes for his Scotch uh
we have E Capture Sunday for Knight
captures and Knight to F6 the Schmidt
variation uh Knight captures B captures
and pawn to E5 with Knight to D5 all
very standard here uh C4 here is the
main move Bishop to D3 uh second most uh
common idea with these six characters
captures and Bishop to E4 now only one
uh game ever reached this position uh
and in that game Queen to E7 was played
here we have Bishop to A6 a very nice
spawn Sacrifice by Hikaru uh who knows
how long he's been preparing this one
but it uh it definitely should shouldn't
be pleasant to play this so okay Wesley
accepts the sacrifice Bishop can't
respawn characters and queen characters
and now Wesley is up upon but his King
will be stuck in the center at least for
the moment he will probably have to play
some like a knight to C3 Bishop D2 or E3
and Castle Queen side so it's going to
be a very sharp game
uh Rook the C8 you could also consider
some like Queen t7 check but it just
doesn't do all that much for example
Queen E7 check Bishop to E3 uh I mean
The Rook is hanging let's say Rook the
C8 Knight to C3 and there's not much for
black to do here like if you play G6 is
already Game Over The Rook is hanging
and Bishop T4 check will pick up the
bishop uh so black will just resign here
so instead just Rook the C8 you will
play Bishop to E7 in just Castle uh
Knight to C3 with Bishop to E7 and now
Bishop to E3 Bishop to C4 getting the
Queen off of such an active Square
Quinta D2 and queen to A5 now we have
Pawn to A3 and pawn to D5 we have
knighted D1 Wesley offers a queen trade
and Hikaru declines with Queen to C7
with Bishop D4 attacking G7 and Hikaru
just castles here with knights the E3
and the bishop to G5 now pinning the
Knight here Castles by Wesley and now
Rook the E8 we have King the B1
unpinning from this nasty diagonal and
now Pawn to A5 with a Ponte H4 uh
expanding on the on the king side uh or
you want to of course play H5 H6 and put
pressure on the G7 Pawn so here Hikaru
says all right let's just trade cappers
characters and I'm gonna stop your
advancement with uh Pawn to H5 now uh if
Wesley was really really desperate to
try anything here G4 might not actually
be a bad try just to open up lines of
attack in front of the black king but he
goes Rook H to E1 uh we have A4 and now
Bishop to D4 Wesley is just up a clean
pawn and he doesn't have all that much
to worry about as long as the C2 Pawn is
protected uh he can just trade and try
and enjoy his extra Pawn with Ponte F6
by Hikaru limiting the power of this
dark Square Bishop with Rook cap for 78
to Rook captures and now Rook the E1
offering a rook trade Hikaru defends his
rook and and now Rook the E3 uh Hikaru
trades with captures captures and queen
to G4 now and Hikaru says Alright you're
still up a pawn but my position is very
very solid uh Bishops are of opposite
colors if you trade Queens it's not
going to be easy uh and one thing I have
to worry about is something like Queens
coming off the board uh whistle getting
his King to C3 and then just playing B3
creating two connected pass pawns on the
queen side that could be a problem so
okay G3 uh Wesley defends the H for pawn
queen H3 and now Queen to D1 we have
Queen to F5 and King the C1 we have
Queen to E5 and now Bishop to D4 chases
away the queen queen E4 Bishop to E3 and
queen to E5 now we have Queen to D4 uh
and Hikaru declines the trade for the
reason that we already gave if you trade
here then it's just getting the king to
C3 and playing B3 it's
um very very hard to stop this laser
King G6 King three King F5 G3 V3
captures captures and the two connected
pass pawns will be
uh well pretty much Unstoppable so
instead Queen to F5 with King to D2 and
now Queen to D7 uh with King to C3 uh
King to H7 and now Pawn to B3 the past
pawns are now created with Bishop to B5
Hikaru says all right if you if you
wanna capture at least let's uh mess up
your Pawn structure so Queen to C5 puts
pressure on the bishop now the king is
coming to B4 as well uh King to h8
Hikaru just uh you know doing nothing
waiting to see what Wesley will try King
to B4 attacks the bishop and the bishop
back to E2 we have King to C3 and now
Bishop back to B5 with King to B2 and
now King to H7 Hikaru says I'm happy
with the draw here a draw is a victory
in Armageddon uh so Wesley has to try
something Bishop to D4 we have King to
h8 now Bishop to C3 and Bishop to C6
just keeping an eye and everything Queen
to D4 and now King to G8 we have Queen
the f 4 and now King to F7 Bishop to D4
and now Queen to E7 so not not much
Happening Here Queen to E3 Wesley offers
a queen trade and Hikaru again declines
uh with Bishop to C5 now you have to be
careful otherwise you might allow the
the White Queen to infiltrate if the
black queen moves so King to G8 with
Queen to E7 and now Queen to C8 with
Queen to D6 uh and the King to H7 Hikaru
just still standing still Bishop to D4
and now Queen to E8 with Pawn to F3 now
uh a capture Sun B3 uh and now we have
uh King captures on B3 uh you could also
play C captures on B3 probably Wesley
thought this was better to prevent any
uh checks from the second rank this way
he will be able to avoid more checks uh
and he still does have the past a pawn
so Bishop to A4 check King to beat you
and now Queen to E2 putting pressure on
that C2 Pawn so Queen C7 defends the
pawn and also might be having some nasty
ideas of Bishop captures and F6
uh so just Queen to B5 with check King
to C3 and now King to G6 getting the
king out of Harm's Way King to D2 Queen
to F1 uh putting pressure on that F3
pawn and just Queen the C3 nicely
defending uh Queen to G2 with check King
to C1 and now Queen captures on G3 we
have Queen to D3 with check King to F7
and now Queen to F5 putting pressure on
that D5 Pawn so Queen captures an H4
Queen captures and D5 with checking to
G6 and now King to B2 uh We've queened
the F4 and now Queen to C4 not all that
much to do for Wesley now uh it is uh
Hikaru who will be pushing for the win
as that H Pawn does seem to be
unstoppable so Queen to B8 uh sorry
Queen to B8 with check with King to C3
and now Queen to B5 offering a queen
trade uh here you have to trade it
there's uh really not all that much you
you can try here with captures cam
actress and now uh interestingly uh
there is a way to save the game uh but
uh whistle doesn't really gain anything
by that so uh Wesley played something
other than the the move that saves the
game but uh just in case you guys are
interested feel free to pause the video
and try to find the only move that saves
the game uh for white while I give you a
couple of seconds
foreign
for those of you who were able to do it
congratulations on being a true Master
of the end game and for those of you who
just want to enjoy the show it is King
to D2 this is the only move that saves
the game you have to beat that H Pawn
um before it becomes a queen for example
H4 where you're gonna play King to E3
and now you are very happy uh if if
something like Ponte H2 you can play
King to F2 and you will be in time to
stop that pawn and if you don't uh even
try it all the way uh after let's say
King T3 let's say Bishop to D7 uh you
can just play uh whatever King to F2 and
again you are uh you are in time and you
will be stopping this pawn and now uh
slowly but surely you will figure out a
way how to how to start advancing your
own pawns however in the game Wesley
played King the B4 and this is now just
straight out winning for Hikaru he plays
Bishop D2 goes after the F3 Pawn that
was the uh the the one that you had to
go go after and there's no good way to
save it if you play something like Ponte
Ford and King F5 and I mean there is not
all that much to be done here with
Bishop E3 now H4 you cannot defend both
this and the H2 Square you have to
defend the H2 Square in order to
represent h3h H uh two so let's say A4
You're Gonna Play H3 Bishop to G1 you
have to stop this now King captures A5
uh King to G3 knocking to C5 and you
don't really care King to G2 the bishop
has to move and you win the game easily
and the bishop covers the A6 Square so
you don't have to worry about the a pawn
uh so instead after Bishop E2 A4 was
played by Wesley but now Bishop captures
an F3 Pawn to C4 uh and King to F5 we
have King to C5 and here King to E6 was
played and it was in this position and
move 70 that Wesley so resigned the game
as there is nothing more to be done here
so the reason you resign here is because
the bishop is too strong there's just no
way to push those pawns for white you're
blocking your own pawns you're gonna
have to wait waste a few moves to block
the bishop but even that will not help
you it's it's actually a funny
outline so I will show it let's say G5
you have to push both of these pawns
otherwise the bishop will be able to
stop them uh A6 H for A7 G4 now we're
gonna have to move the king to block the
bishop with your C Pawn H3 Bishop to G1
you have to stop H2 G3 C5 uh H2 you're
gonna have to give up the bishop now C6
uh you are blocking the queening square
but now look at this just Bishop
captures and C6 King captures and H1
Queen and that's pretty much it uh
you're gonna block it the pawn and that
that's all there is to it uh so yeah
after King to E6 uh Wesley resigns and
Hikaru will get another crack and Magnus
he proceeds into the uh Grand Final
where he will face Magnus again so like
I said if Hikaru now wins the match then
they will go into the grand grand final
uh where whoever will wins will be the
winner of everything's Masters but if
Hikaru loses in the Grand Final then
that is truly it uh so yeah uh that's
the game hope you guys enjoyed it Wesley
tried everything to win here he was in a
must win situation that's how Armageddon
works and he went for his uh I believe
this is Wesley's pet line I I think he
even has um uh win against uh well a lot
of players but uh against Garrick as
part of amongst others uh so uh he
definitely knows his stuff and which I
think of course Hikaru knew I think uh
uh They even played together this line
several times maybe like it was a
tournament I think called ultimate moves
sometimes maybe during 2016 where I
believe this line was uh very very
popular and that Wesley actually played
it against Hikaru I don't know if he
played against karaoke I'm pretty sure
he played against Kasparov uh but yeah
obviously Hikaru knows that and he knows
how to play against it and what a
spectacular line at the prepare this
this beautiful Pawn sacrifice just
cutting off the king from canceling
King's side forcing him to go into
opposite side muscles I mean beautiful
stuff by Hikaru here so yeah that's the
game hope you guys enjoyed it I would
like to thank Carrie Smith Martin Alden
Marcus grebel bocho and Kenneth
freighter for your contribution
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check two of my previous videos here
thank you for watching and I will see
you soon continuing the coverage of the
finals of the grand finals of the grand
grand finals and however many finals
they come up with so thank you all I
will see you soon and have an excellent
rest of your day